This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Many scientists who study people end up saying some version of the following sentence. The human being is the only animal that has a sense of humor. That can cooperate. That do radio shows. That regularly fashion and use tools. That have. Chins.
这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。许多研究人类的科学家最终都会得出这样一种结论：人类是唯一拥有幽默感的动物。唯一会合作的动物。唯一会做广播节目的动物。唯一会定期制作并使用工具的动物。唯一有下巴的动物。
Psychologist Daniel Gilbert at Harvard University finishes the sentence this way. The human being is the only animal that thinks about the future. Every animal learns from trial and error, human beings learn from experiences they've never even had. They close their eyes and say, what I like liver and onion ice cream, yuck, would it be a good idea to put my finger in a pencil sharpener? No. But just because we humans have great imaginations, it doesn't mean we do a good job of predicting the future accurately. People just aren't very good at looking into their future and predicting
哈佛大学的心理学家丹尼尔·吉尔伯特是这样总结的：人类是唯一会思考未来的动物。每种动物都能从试错中学习，但人类能从从未经历过的事情中学习。他们闭上眼睛想：我喜欢肝脏配洋葱冰淇淋吗？真恶心。把手指伸进卷笔刀是个好主意吗？不。但仅仅因为我们人类拥有丰富的想象力，并不意味着我们能准确地预测未来。人们在展望未来并预测
correctly their emotional reactions to the events that might unfold. We think a dentist appointment will be awful, and then it's not so bad. We think a dentist appointment will be awful and then it's not so bad. We think buying a new car will make us very happy, but it ends up being just nice. We think losing a job is the worst thing that could happen to us and then it becomes the best thing. The problem is once our minds get to work imagining the future, we leave out lots of details, like the nice lady at the front desk at the dentist's office or the free toothbrush. This week on Hidden Brain,
自己对未来可能发生的事件的情绪反应时，表现得并不太好。我们认为看牙医会很糟糕，结果发现其实没那么糟。我们认为看牙医会很糟糕，结果发现其实没那么糟。我们认为买辆新车会让我们非常快乐，但最终发现也就那样。我们认为失业是可能发生在我们身上最糟糕的事情，但后来它却成了最好的事情。问题在于，一旦我们的大脑开始想象未来，我们就会忽略许多细节，比如牙医诊所前台那位友好的女士，或者免费的牙刷。本周在《Hidden Brain》节目中，
we confront how little we actually understand about what we want. And we try to figure out how we can make future versions of ourselves happier. It continues our annual summer series, YouTube.0. Authenticity is contagious. I have been dragged into this all the way kicking and screaming. Ideas and advice about how you can respond to life's chaos.
我们直面这样一个事实：我们对自己想要什么其实知之甚少。我们试图找出如何让未来的自己更快乐的方法。这是我们年度夏季系列节目《YouTube.0》的延续。真实性具有感染力。我一直被连拉带拽地卷入其中，又踢又叫。关于如何应对生活混乱的观点和建议。
Let me do it just check to my inbox. Just check, just check, just check to my phone real quick. With wisdom. Daniel Gilbert is a psychology professor at Harvard University. He's the author of the book, Stumbling on Happiness, and he's one of my favorite researchers in the world. Dan, welcome to Hidden Brain. Well, thank you. You're now my favorite radio hours in the world. Well, that was easy. I want to start by asking you a question that you and I talked about a while ago, Dan. Some years
让我查一下收件箱。查一下，查一下，快速查一下手机。带着智慧。丹尼尔·吉尔伯特是哈佛大学的心理学教授。他是《撞上幸福》一书的作者，也是我世界上最喜欢的科研人员之一。丹，欢迎来到《Hidden Brain》。嗯，谢谢。你现在是我世界上最喜欢的广播节目主持人了。嗯，这太容易了。我想先问你一个你我前段时间讨论过的问题，丹。几年前，
ago, you went through a series of very difficult personal experiences, but instead of leaving you broken-hearted, as you might have anticipated, it left you with actually a very important insight into your own ability to predict your future emotional states. Can you tell me what happened? Well, my personal experiences were no worse than the average person's, in fact, better than most. But, like everybody, I suffer the slings and arrows about rage's fortune. We have divorces, we have surgeries, we have breakups with women we love and friends we enjoy.
你经历了一系列非常困难的个人事件，但这些经历并没有像你预期的那样让你心碎，反而让你对自己预测未来情绪状态的能力有了非常重要的洞察。你能告诉我发生了什么吗？嗯，我的个人经历并不比普通人更糟糕，事实上比大多数人都要好。但是，像每个人一样，我承受着命运的打击。我们经历离婚、手术，与我们深爱的人和我们喜欢的友谊分手。
So it was sort of ordinary events that befell me all in one year. And I realized that had you asked me a year earlier how I would be fairing, the answer would have been, oh my gosh, I'll be devastated, but I wasn't devastated, it wasn't a good year, but it was okay. And it made me wonder if I was the only person who was just too stupid to be able to look ahead into his future and figure out how he'd feel if
所以，这些发生在我身上的一年里的事情算是普通事件。我意识到，如果一年前你问我我会过得怎么样，答案会是：天哪，我会崩溃的。但我并没有崩溃，那不是美好的一年，但还过得去。这让我怀疑，我是不是唯一一个太笨，以至于无法展望未来，无法弄清楚如果
really bad or maybe really good things happened. So I went to the laboratory and teamed up with my friend Tim Wilson and we started studying this phenomenon and you know reassuringly we found out we weren't the only stupid people out there. You've also found that painful decisions are often painful largely because we haven't made them yet. Once we actually make a decision, pick one of two alternatives, we often end up wondering how we could ever have dreamed of choosing the other choice. Well, surely that's true for all of us.
发生非常糟糕甚至非常好的事情时自己会有什么感觉的人。所以我去了实验室，和我的朋友蒂姆·威尔逊合作，我们开始研究这种现象。令人欣慰的是，我们发现我们并不是唯一愚蠢的人。你还发现，痛苦的决定之所以痛苦，很大程度上是因为我们还没有做出决定。一旦我们真正做出了决定，选择了两个选项中的一个，我们往往会怀疑自己当初怎么会想到选择另一个选项。嗯，这对我们所有人来说肯定都是真的。
We agonize between two things that seem awfully close. We finally choose one. And in a small or medium amount of time, we look back and wonder how we could ever have been trying to decide between them. Why did we make that mistake of thinking the two alternatives were so close when, in fact, they were really far apart? The answer is they weren't really close, and they weren't really far apart. It's just a matter of how you look at it. And when you're on the front side of a decision,
我们在两个看起来非常接近的事情之间纠结。我们最终选择了其中一个。在一段或长或短的时间后，我们回过头来，想知道自己当初怎么会在这两者之间犹豫不决。为什么我们会犯下那种认为两个选项如此接近的错误，而事实上它们相差甚远？答案是它们并不真的接近，也不真的相差甚远。这只是你看待它的方式问题。当你处于决策的前期时，
alternatives seem to be very close, but once you've chosen one, the mind gets going doing what the mind does so well. Convincing you that the thing you've got is better than the thing you've left behind. Now, if psychologists are trying to cure that, we call it rationalization. If we're trying to sell it, we call it coping.
选项看起来非常接近，但一旦你选择了其中一个，大脑就会开始做它最擅长的事情。说服你，你得到的东西比你放弃的东西更好。现在，如果心理学家试图治愈这种行为，我们称之为合理化。如果我们试图推销它，我们称之为应对。
But whether you call it coping or rationalization, it's the same thing. It's the mind-finding realistic ways to see the world so that it feels better about the world in which it finds itself. You once subscribed to the very popular belief that I think I still subscribed to, that more freedom always equals more happiness. And if I remember correctly, you conducted a study once that found that this wasn't quite right. And at the time, I think you told me that you'd been living with your girlfriend for more than a decade. And you saw the data and you decided to make some changes in your life.
但无论你称之为应对还是合理化，它们都是一回事。这是大脑在寻找现实的方式来看待世界，以便让自己对所处的世界感觉更好。你曾经信奉一个非常流行的观点，我想我至今仍信奉，即更多的自由总是等于更多的幸福。如果我没记错的话，你曾经做过一项研究，发现这并不完全正确。当时，我想你告诉我你和你的女朋友已经同居十多年了。你看到了数据，决定改变一下你的生活。
You have a very good memory. So like many people, I used to believe that the more freedom, the better. How could you be less happy when you had more choice? Well we know now a lot about why more choice sometimes makes people less happy. In our study, we brought students in and we created a photography course and we had all of them work with us for a long time learning how to do black and white photography. Then at the end of the course, we gave them two photographs that they had taken, and we said they could keep one and we were going to keep one. Well, this was horrible for them. They wanted to keep both. They had a tough decision to make. In one group, we said, if you ever change your mind about which photograph you want,
你的记性真好。所以像许多人一样，我过去认为自由越多越好。当你拥有更多选择时，怎么可能不那么快乐呢？嗯，我们现在很清楚为什么更多的选择有时会让人们不那么快乐。在我们的研究中，我们请来学生，开设了一门摄影课程，让他们和我们一起工作了很长时间，学习如何进行黑白摄影。然后在课程结束时，我们给了他们两张他们拍摄的照片，并告诉他们可以留下一张，另一张由我们保留。嗯，这对他们来说太糟糕了。他们想两张都留着。他们必须做出艰难的决定。在第一组中，我们说，如果你改变了主意，想要另一张照片，
just let us know. We'll swap with you. We're going to keep this unfile forever. So if you took A and you want B, we'll swap B for A, for as long as we both shall live. Another group was told your decision is final. Once you make this decision, the photograph that you're donating to us gets sent off to England, it'll never be seen again. And of course, if you presented those choices to me, I would say I would want to be in the first group because I would preserve my options if I took a photograph home and didn't like it, I could come back and trade it in for the one that I did like. Exactly, and that's not even just a good guess.
随时告诉我们。我们会和你交换。我们会永远保留这张照片。所以如果你选了A，想要B，只要我们还活着，我们就会为你交换。另一组被告知你的决定是最终的。一旦你做出决定，你捐给我们的照片就会被送到英国，再也不会被看到了。当然，如果你把这些选择摆在我面前，我会说我想在第一组，因为我会保留我的选择权。如果我带回家一张照片却不喜欢，我可以回来换成我喜欢的那张。没错，这甚至不仅仅是一个好的猜测。
We actually did exactly that in another study. We asked people which group they wanted to be in and just like you, they overwhelmingly want to be in the first group. But what's interesting is we tracked the happiness of the people who had made these decisions over the course of several weeks. And what we found is that people who made an irrevocable decision, one they couldn't change, were much happier with the choice they made. When you've made an irrevocable decision, you rationalize it.
我们在另一项研究中确实做了完全相同的事情。我们问人们他们想在哪一组，就像你一样，他们绝大多数人想在第一组。但有趣的是，我们追踪了这些在几周内做出决定的人的幸福感。我们发现，做出不可撤销决定（即无法更改的决定）的人，对他们所做的选择要快乐得多。当你做出不可撤销的决定时，你会将其合理化。
Once something's gone and gone forever, the mind gets to work figuring out why, what it got is really better than what it lost. But when a decision isn't irrevocable, when you can remake it and revisit it and change your mind anytime, what do you do? You just ruminate about it, right? You buy a sweater and you know you can take it back anytime and every time you put it on, you look in the mirror and you think, I don't know, maybe it's not a good fit, maybe it's not a good color, maybe I ought to bring it back. On the other hand, if this sweater was bought at a place that won't take it back, you look in the mirror and you say, gosh, that looks good.
一旦某样东西永远消失了，大脑就会开始思考为什么，为什么你得到的东西真的比你失去的东西更好。但当一个决定不是不可撤销的，当你随时可以重新做出决定、重新审视并改变主意时，你会怎么做？你只会反复琢磨它，对吧？你买了一件毛衣，你知道你可以随时退货，每次穿上它，你看着镜子就会想：我不知道，也许它不合身，也许颜色不好，也许我应该把它退回去。另一方面，如果这件毛衣是在一个不接受退货的地方买的，你看着镜子会说：天哪，这看起来真不错。
So you took this research and you applied it to your own life. I did. I think my then girlfriend and I had been living together for about a decade. And once we saw the results of this experiment and a friend of mine, Dave Myers, called and said, you know, I think this really explains the difference between living together and getting married Which had never occurred to me. I thought, you know, if you're a scientist and you don't live by your own results What kind of scientist are you? So yeah, I went home and proposed and guess what? I was utterly right I love her so much more now that we're married now that I can't get out of this relationship no matter how fast I run, she is the love of my life. And I didn't realize that when I was always thinking,
所以你把这项研究应用到了你自己的生活中。我确实应用了。我想我和当时的女朋友已经同居了大约十年。当我们看到这个实验的结果时，我的朋友戴夫·迈尔斯打电话说：你知道，我认为这真的解释了同居和结婚之间的区别。这我以前从未想到过。我想，你知道，如果你是一名科学家，却不按照自己的研究结果生活，那你算什么科学家？所以是的，我回家求婚了，你猜怎么着？我完全正确。我现在比我们结婚前更爱她，既然我无论跑多快都无法逃离这段关系，她就是我生命中的挚爱。而当我总是想着
should I stay or shouldn't I stay? There's a lot to be said for making commitments. So let's talk a little bit about why these errors often happen. One idea that you've explored is that when we imagine the future, we often fail to take into account all the little details that will actually make us happy or sad. Well it's true, every future event comprises thousands and thousands of details, but when
我该留下还是离开时，我并没有意识到这一点。做出承诺有很多好处。那么，让我们谈谈为什么这些错误经常发生。你探索过的一个观点是，当我们想象未来时，我们往往无法考虑到所有那些实际上会让我们快乐或悲伤的小细节。嗯，这是真的，每一个未来的事件都包含成千上万的细节，但当
you ask people to imagine a future event, they usually imagine one or two of those details, the ones that are central that define the episode. So if I say to you, imagine the next visit to the dentist, probably you get a picture in your head instantly of sitting in a chair and someone's fooling around in your mouth. Well, that is indeed a part of the experience you'll have. But you also have to park. You're also going to be in the waiting room. They're going to be playing music. There will be magazines. The receptionist will be nice or not. Afterwards, you will or won't have an appointment. You need to rush to. There's lots of other parts of that experience
你要求人们想象一个未来的事件时，他们通常只会想象其中一两个细节，即那些定义该事件的核心细节。所以如果我对你说，想象一下下次看牙医，你脑海中可能立刻会出现坐在椅子上，有人在你的嘴里摆弄的画面。嗯，那确实是你将要经历的一部分。但你还得停车。你还得在候诊室里待着。他们会放音乐。会有杂志。接待员可能会很友好，也可能不会。之后，你可能需要也可能不需要预约。你需要赶去哪里。那次经历中还有很多其他部分
that you're not imagining, and all of them can affect your happiness. Now, you can't imagine every detail. That's not possible. But what you ought to do rationally is think to yourself, I'm only imagining one or two of the many pieces of the experience, and as a result, I should be very humble about my prediction. But nobody is. Instead they say, a dental visit? Oh, hate it! One of the
是你没有想象到的，而所有这些都会影响你的幸福感。现在，你不可能想象出每一个细节。那是不可能的。但你理应理性地对自己说：我只是在想象这段经历中众多片段中的一两个，因此，对于我的预测，我应该保持谦逊。但没有人这样做。相反，他们说：看牙医？哦，讨厌！在这一研究领域中，你发现的最有趣的事情之一是，
most interesting things you found in this line of research is that it's not just that we don't imagine the event in the future in all its fullness and detail. We also don't fully appreciate that we might not quite be the same people we are then that we are now. You know, we might not quite be the same people we are then that we are now. You know I think that's even the more powerful of the two errors. So you're quite right. One problem is that we don't imagine events correctly. We don't imagine them as they will unfold. That's the smaller of the two problems. The larger problem is that we don't know who we will be when we are experiencing
我们不仅没有想象出未来事件的全部细节。我们也没有充分意识到，未来的我们可能与现在的我们并不完全相同。你知道，我们可能与未来的我们并不完全相同。你知道，我认为这比前两个错误更严重。所以你说得很对。一个问题是我们没有正确地想象事件。我们没有按照它们将要展开的方式去想象它们。这是两个问题中较小的一个。更大的问题是，我们不知道当我们在经历
that event. We underestimate the mind's ability to react to events in a different way than it's reacting to them in prospect. Things look different from out the windshield and in the rearview mirror. Life is like that too. Almost every event you experience feels different once you've experienced it, then you imagined it would have beforehand. That's the part of our psychology. We don't seem very good at anticipating. Do I recall a study that you did recently which tracked
那个事件时，我们会是谁。我们低估了大脑以不同于预期的方式对事件做出反应的能力。从挡风玻璃看出去和从后视镜看回来，事情看起来是不一样的。生活也是如此。几乎你经历的每一件事，一旦你真正经历过，感觉就和你之前想象的完全不同。这是我们心理学的一部分。我们似乎不太擅长预见这一点。我记得你最近做的一项研究，追踪了
people over the course of their lives and asked them how they imagined they would change in the future versus how they had changed in the past? You are remembering correctly. We recently published a paper showing that when people are asked to predict how much they will change in the future, they underestimate it. Look, we all know 18-year-olds are crazy. They think they are who they are. They're going to be that way forever. They have crazy hairstyles and tattoos that they believe they're going to want for
人们一生的轨迹，询问他们如何想象自己在未来会发生变化，以及他们过去是如何变化的？你记得很对。我们最近发表了一篇论文，表明当人们被要求预测自己在未来会发生多少变化时，他们低估了这一点。看，我们都知道18岁的人很疯狂。他们认为他们就是他们现在的样子。他们会永远那样下去。他们留着疯狂的发型，纹着他们相信自己会想要
the rest of their lives. And old people like me snicker and go, you're going to see. Because 18-year-olds underestimate how different they're gonna be when they're 28. And we showed this in our experiment by asking 18-year-olds to tell us how much they would change in the next 10 years, and asking 28-year-olds to tell us how much they had changed in the last 10 years. In a perfectly rational world, those numbers would be the same and they weren't. 18-year-olds thought they would change very little, 28-year-olds reported having changed a lot. But what's so interesting about the study is it's also true with 58-year-olds and 68-year-olds.
一辈子的纹身。而像我这样的老年人会窃笑说：走着瞧吧。因为18岁的人低估了他们在28岁时会有多大的不同。我们在实验中通过要求18岁的人告诉我们他们在未来10年内会发生多少变化，并要求28岁的人告诉我们他们在过去10年里发生了多少变化来证明了这一点。在一个完全理性的世界里，这些数字应该是相同的，但事实并非如此。18岁的人认为他们几乎不会改变，28岁的人报告说他们改变了很多。但这项研究最有趣的地方在于，对于58岁和68岁的人来说也是如此。
That is, 58-year-olds think, okay, I'm done, I'm cooked. It'll just be me, maybe a little flabier, more wrinkles, but I'm the guy I'm going to be. 68-year-olds look back to the last 10 years and say, wow, have I changed. So what's really fascinating about this down is that no matter how many times we experience these errors in our lives and how many times we make the same mistakes, somehow we don't learn from them and we're left with the same confidence that we had before that now, this time, when I predict the future, I'm going to be right. There are two kinds of errors.
也就是说，58岁的人认为：好吧，我完了，我定型了。我还是我，可能稍微胖一点，皱纹多一点，但我就是我。68岁的人回顾过去10年说：哇，我改变了多少啊。所以丹，真正令人着迷的是，无论我们在生活中经历多少次这些错误，无论我们犯多少次同样的错误，我们似乎都不会从中吸取教训，我们依然像以前一样自信，认为这一次，当我预测未来时，我会是对的。有两种错误。
Sometimes you're driving some place and you take the wrong route. The next time you always get it right. But then there are errors that are more like, oh, optical illusions. You know, you see those two parallel lines on the page and you say, gosh, they don't look parallel to me and then you measure them and they are, but then you stand back and they don't look that way. So you measure them again, but they are, but they keep not looking that way. I think the kinds of errors we're talking about are a little bit more like optical illusions.
有时你开车去某个地方，走错了路。下一次你总是能走对。但还有一些错误更像是视错觉。你知道，你看到页面上的那两条平行线，你说：天哪，它们看起来不平行。然后你测量它们，它们确实是平行的，但当你退后一步看，它们看起来又不平行了。所以你再次测量它们，它们确实是平行的，但它们看起来依然不平行。我认为我们正在讨论的这类错误更像是视错觉。
You can't help but see the future in this deficient way. Time and time again, you will find your predictions were wrong and time and time again, you'll make the same predictions. When we come back I'm going to ask Dan how we can use insights from his research to help us make decisions that are more likely to make us happier in the future. Stay with us. I asked Dan to tell me whether he's found ways to help people use their imaginations to make better decisions for their future selves.
你无法不以这种有缺陷的方式看待未来。一次又一次，你会发现你的预测是错误的，而一次又一次，你依然会做出同样的预测。当我们回来时，我要问丹，我们如何利用他的研究见解来帮助我们做出更有可能让我们在未来更快乐的决定。请继续收听。我请丹告诉我，他是否找到了帮助人们利用想象力为未来的自己做出更好决定的方法。
We and many others have spent decades trying to figure out how can we make human imagination better. If when people look into the future, they make mistakes, what kind of training could we give them so they don't make these mistakes? And I will give you the summary of 15 years of research. It doesn't work. Almost nothing anybody has ever tried makes a long lasting broad difference. On the other hand, the best way to predict your future we've discovered is not to close your eyes and use your imagination. There is a completely different
我们和其他许多人花了数十年时间试图弄清楚如何让人的想象力变得更好。如果人们在展望未来时会犯错，我们能给他们什么样的训练，让他们不犯这些错误？我将给你总结15年的研究成果。这行不通。几乎没有人尝试过的方法能产生持久且广泛的差异。另一方面，我们发现预测未来的最好方法不是闭上眼睛使用你的想象力。有一种完全不同的
discovered is not to close your eyes and use your imagination. There is a completely different way to figure out how you will feel. And that is to ask people who are already in your future how they feel. Almost anything you're imagining. Should I move to Hawaii? Should I become a trumpet player? I wonder how I should subscribe to the New York Times would it be better to have a bagel or a beale? Almost any decision you're debating, large or small, many people have already made it and they've made it in both
方法来弄清楚你会有什么感觉。那就是去问那些已经在你的未来的人，他们感觉如何。几乎任何你正在想象的事情。我应该搬到夏威夷吗？我应该成为一名小号手吗？我想知道我是否应该订阅《纽约时报》，吃百吉饼还是吃比尔饼会更好？几乎任何你正在争论的决定，无论大小，许多人已经做出了决定，而且他们已经做出了
directions. There are people who are doing the things you're only imagining. And it turns out that if you can simply measure their happiness, you can get a pretty good guide about how happy you will be in the future. One of the experiments that we did that demonstrated this most simply is we created a speed dating clinic where young women came in and they had a speed date with a young man. And they were offered one of two kinds of information. Either they could learn all about the young man before they met him, they could see his photograph, learn his hobbies, find out about his likes and his dislikes, or they could learn none of that and they could get just one piece of information, namely, how much did the woman who already had
两个方向的决定。有些人正在做你只是在想象的事情。事实证明，如果你能简单地衡量他们的幸福感，你就能得到一个关于你未来会有多快乐的很好的指南。我们所做的最简单地证明这一点的实验之一是，我们创建了一个快速约会诊所，年轻女性进来，与一名年轻男子进行快速约会。她们被提供了两种信息中的一种。要么她们可以在见面之前了解关于这个年轻男子的所有信息，她们可以看到他的照片，了解他的爱好，找出他的喜好和厌恶，要么她们可以什么都不了解，只得到一条信息，即已经和他
a speed date with him enjoy it? Well, it turns out, first of all, everybody wants the first kind of information. Women in our study all think they're going to make a much better prediction of how much they'll enjoy the date if they can just learn about the guy. But what we find is that they're much more accurate in predicting their own experience if they know nothing except another woman's experience. This woman is in a sense a surrogate for their future selves and we call this method surrogation using other people's experiences a guide to your own.
进行过快速约会的女性有多享受这次约会？嗯，事实证明，首先，每个人都想要第一种信息。我们研究中的女性都认为，如果她们能了解这个男人，她们就能更准确地预测自己会有多享受这次约会。但我们发现，如果她们除了另一个女性的经历之外什么都不知道，她们在预测自己的体验时会准确得多。这个女性在某种意义上是她们未来自己的代理人，我们称这种方法为代理法，即利用他人的经历作为你自己的指南。
So there's a commercial application basically is built on this idea. It's called YEP. Exactly right. There are a few domains in which we all know that we want to rely on other people's reviews, if you will. Movies and restaurants, those are the two big domains. Now why are we willing to rely on other people in these domains? Because we can't imagine for ourselves.
所以基本上有一个商业应用是建立在这个想法上的。它叫Yelp。完全正确。我们都知道在少数几个领域，我们想要依赖他人的评论。电影和餐馆，这是两个大领域。现在，为什么我们愿意在这些领域依赖他人？因为我们无法为自己想象。
I mean, if I say how much do you think you'll enjoy the new restaurant, you look at me and go, how can I possibly close my eyes and imagine that? When we have no information about a future event, we become surrogators, we're willing to listen to other people. But if you offer folks, even the smallest piece of information about a future event, they will take that over all the Yelp reviews. So let me ask you, you're going to decide whether to spend a lot of money to buy a movie. Would you rather see the trailer or would you rather read reviews?
我的意思是，如果我问你觉得你会多享受这家新餐馆，你看着我会说：我怎么可能闭上眼睛想象那个？当我们对未来事件没有任何信息时，我们就会成为代理人，我们愿意听取他人的意见。但如果你给人们提供关于未来事件的哪怕最小的一点信息，他们也会选择那个信息，而不是所有的Yelp评论。所以让我问你，你要决定是否花很多钱买一部电影。你宁愿看预告片还是宁愿读评论？
If you're like most people, you would throw out all the reviews by every critic and every Yelp earned the world if you could just see the trailer. Because you trust your own judgment in some ways better than others. You feel if you could just taste 30 seconds, 60 seconds of the movie, you'll know if it's the kind of movie you like, but you won't. Other people's reviews are going to be great information about things like, did the movie go on too long? Did the plot get predictable? Did God come out of a machine in the end? All sorts of things you'll never get from a trailer. And yet, if you offer people these two kinds of information, the trailer every time.
如果你像大多数人一样，只要能看预告片，你就会扔掉世界上所有评论家和Yelp用户的评论。因为你在某种程度上比别人更信任自己的判断。你觉得如果你能品尝30秒、60秒的电影，你就会知道这是否是你喜欢的电影类型，但你不会知道。他人的评论将是关于诸如“电影是否太长了？”、“情节是否变得可预测？”、“最后是否有神来之笔？”等各种你永远无法从预告片中得到的信息的绝佳来源。然而，如果你给人们提供这两种信息，他们每次都会选择预告片。
So would you suggest that we should actually have Yelp for everything, that we should be rating our friends and spouses and children and professors, all via this kind of distributed review system? Well, as a professor, I do get rated already. So there is a review system for me. And, you know, at Harvard, we have a quaint tradition. It's called Shopping Week. And in the first week of school, all the students come in and they visit classes. They don't choose their classes ahead of time. They visit them all to see 15 or 20 minutes of a lecture
所以你会建议我们实际上应该为所有事情建立Yelp，我们应该通过这种分布式评论系统来评价我们的朋友、配偶、孩子和教授吗？嗯，作为一名教授，我已经得到了评价。所以确实有一个针对我的评价系统。而且，你知道，在哈佛，我们有一个古老的传统。它叫“购物周”。在开学的第一周，所有的学生都会进来参观课程。他们不会提前选择课程。他们会参观所有的课程，看15或20分钟的讲座，
because they're convinced, and the administration is convinced, that they can tell from 20 minutes of someone's lecture whether they'll really enjoy and get a lot out of the class. What they're ignoring is a huge database of information from people who actually sat through the class for 15 weeks and have a whole lot to say about whether you'll enjoy it or not. You can't convince a student to take a class that has great reviews if they didn't like the 10 minutes of the first lecture. The problem is something we call the illusion of diversity.
因为他们确信，行政部门也确信，他们可以通过某人20分钟的讲座判断他们是否真的会享受并从这门课中获得很多东西。他们忽略的是一个巨大的信息数据库，来自那些真正坐下来听了15周课程的人，他们对你是否会享受这门课有很多话要说。如果学生不喜欢第一节课的10分钟，你就无法说服他们去上一门评价很高的课。问题在于我们所说的“多样性错觉”。
We think we are utterly unique that other people's experiences might tell us a little bit about ours, but not very much because after all, we're so different than everybody. Well nonsense, you're not different than everybody, we're basically all the same. You know, if a Martian knew everything there was to know, everything there was to know about a single human being on Earth, that Martian would know 90% of what there is to know about everybody on Earth. I have to push back just a little bit, because there's also been, I think, a voluminous research conducted by maybe colleagues in the psychology department, which finds that these reviews are
我们认为我们是完全独特的，他人的经历可能告诉我们一点关于我们自己的信息，但不会太多，因为毕竟，我们和每个人都如此不同。嗯，胡说八道，你并不比每个人都不同，我们基本上都是一样的。你知道，如果一个火星人知道关于地球上某一个人类所能知道的一切，那个火星人就会知道关于地球上每个人90%的信息。我必须稍微反驳一下，因为我认为，也许心理学系的同事们也进行了大量的研究，发现这些评论
also shot through with all kinds of biases. So female professors, for example, get much worse reviews than male professors when they're just as good. I mean, isn't there a risk in essentially outsourcing your judgment to the crowd when the crowd actually is capable fully of having, you know, collective biases? Well, two things to say about this first, if you share the biases of the reviewers, they will correctly predict how you will feel, even if it's unfair. So let's say you just don't like old guys like me.
也充满了各种偏见。例如，女性教授在表现同样出色时，得到的评价却比男性教授差得多。我的意思是，当群体完全有能力拥有集体偏见时，将你的判断外包给群体难道没有风险吗？嗯，关于这一点有两件事要说：首先，如果你和评论者有相同的偏见，他们会准确地预测你的感受，即使这是不公平的。所以假设你就是不喜欢像我这样的老家伙。
Let's say there's a bias. Students can't stand to hear a guy in his 50s, Yammer and Yammer. Well, that's not very fair, that's Aegis, that's wrong. On the other hand, when the students say I hated it, it's a pretty good guide for another 18-year-old who will probably hate it for all the same reasons. The second point I'd make is this,
假设存在一种偏见。学生们无法忍受听一个50多岁的人喋喋不休。嗯，那不太公平，那是年龄歧视，那是错误的。另一方面，当学生们说“我讨厌它”时，对于另一个可能因为同样原因而讨厌它的18岁年轻人来说，这是一个很好的指南。我要说的第二点是，
I'm not saying that surrogation is a perfect way to make decisions. You know, Winston Churchill once said, democracy is the worst form of government except for the others. Well, surrogation is a terrible way to make predictions about your own future happiness, except for the other way to make predictions. You know, imagination is so utterly flawed that surrogation, even with all of its problems,
我并不是说代理法是做决定的完美方式。你知道，温斯顿·丘吉尔曾经说过，民主是最糟糕的政府形式，除了其他所有形式。嗯，代理法是一种预测你自己未来幸福感的糟糕方式，除了其他预测方式之外。你知道，想象力是如此彻底地有缺陷，以至于代理法，尽管有所有的问题，
turns out to be a better method than that. Now, if there's a third way to make them, I'm very open to hearing about it, but we've never discovered it. One other idea that you and others have found is that uncertainty can amplify the emotional potency of events that happy surprises and unhappy surprises make a bigger impact on us than happy things that we know are going to happen
结果证明是一种比那更好的方法。现在，如果有第三种方法，我非常乐意听取，但我们从未发现过。你和其他人发现的另一个观点是，不确定性可以放大事件的情绪效力，即快乐的惊喜和不快乐的惊喜比我们知道会发生的快乐事情和我们知道会发生的悲伤事情对我们的影响更大。为什么会这样，我们能从中吸取什么教训？嗯，毫无疑问，不确定性可以放大情绪。所以如果我告诉你某件坏事即将发生，它可能不会像意外发生时那样糟糕。对于好的事件也是如此。我们几十年来，甚至几个世纪以来都知道这一点，这并不是什么特别深刻的观察。我们发现真正有趣的是，尽管这是事实，但人们从不想要不确定性。他们回避它。他们花钱不想要它。
and sad things that we know are going to happen. Why is this and how can we learn from it? Well there's no doubt that uncertainty can amplify emotions. So if I tell you something bad is about to happen, it's probably not going to be quite as bad as if it happens by surprise. And the same is true of good events. We've known that for decades, if not centuries, and that's not a particularly deep observation. What we found really interesting is that even though this is true, people never want uncertainty. They issue it. They pay good money not to have it.
我们做了一项研究，人们观看一部电影，对于我们实验中的一些人，我们不让他们看电影是如何结束的。我们不让他们看到主角发生了什么。然而，我问你，这两部电影中你更想看哪一部？百分之百的人举手说，请让我看电影的结局。但我们发现的是，那些没有看到电影结局的人更喜欢它，思考它的时间更长，即使在几小时或几天后，他们仍然沉浸其中并享受它。
We did a study in which people watched a movie, and for some of the people in our experiment, we didn't let them watch how the movie ended. We didn't let them see what happened to the main character. However, I asked you, which of these two movies would you rather see? A hundred percent of the hands go up and said, like to see the end of the movie, please. But what we discovered was, people who didn't see the end of the movie liked it more, thought about it for longer, were still engaged in it and still enjoying it, even hours or days later.
他们没有看到主角最后发生了什么，所以他们一直在想：天哪，我想知道他是否上了大学，或者他是否成为了足球运动员。思考并享受这些是一件多么有趣的事情。所以重点是，一点点不确定性可以让你非常快乐，但我们似乎从不想要它。如果明天你的门口出现了鲜花，没有纸条，只写着“秘密崇拜者”，我敢打赌你会付我很多钱去找出那个秘密崇拜者是谁，但我保证无论他是谁，
They didn't see what happened the last, the main character in the end, and so they kept wondering, gosh, I wonder if he went to college or he became a football player. What an interesting thing to be thinking about and enjoying. So the point is that a little bit of uncertainty can make you very happy, but we never seem to want it. If flowers showed up on your doorstep tomorrow, with no note, just said secret admirer, I bet you'd pay me a lot to find out who the secret admirer was, but I guarantee you no matter who it is, it's better off
拥有一个秘密崇拜者比知道是谁送的花更好。你是否真的尝试并积极地在自己的生活中为积极事件建立神秘感？我不告诉你。丹，我想感谢你今天与我交谈。这真的很有趣。当然，对我来说也很有趣。谢谢。本周的节目由马克斯·内斯特拉克制作，珍妮·施密特编辑。我们的团队包括雷娜·科恩、帕茨·沙、托马斯·刘和劳拉·夸拉尔。我们的监制是塔拉·博伊尔。
just having a secret admirer than knowing who sent the flowers. Do you actually try and actively build mystery into your own life when it comes to positive events? I'm not telling. Dan, I want to thank you for talking with me today. This has really been fun. Sure, been fun for me too. Thank you. This week's show was produced by Max Nestrak and edited by Jenny Schmidt. Our team includes Raina Cohen, Parts Shah, Thomas Liu and Laura Quarral. Our supervising producer is Tara Boyle.
本周的无名英雄是奥黛丽·霍姆格伦。奥黛丽今年早些时候开始收听《Hidden Brain》，并对我们与诺贝尔奖得主经济学家阿尔·罗斯的对话很感兴趣。这个故事激励奥黛丽去了解更多关于成为肾脏捐赠者的信息。她发现自己与她的朋友亚历克斯匹配，亚历克斯一直在等待名单上。手术定于今年9月9日，我非常兴奋。我很高兴能给别人一个机会，让他们重回正轨。奥黛丽，你的同情心和慷慨使你成为一名无名英雄，不仅是对我们的节目，对整个宇宙也是如此。我们会在9月9日为你和亚历克斯祈祷。
This week's unsung hero is Audrey Homgren. Audrey started listening to Hidden Brain earlier this year and was intrigued by our conversation with Nobel Prize winning economist Al Roth. The story inspired Audrey to learn more about becoming a kidney donor. She discovered she's a match for her friend Alex who's been on the waiting list. Surgery is on September 9th of this year and I am so excited. I'm so happy to give an opportunity to someone else to get their life back on track. Audrey, your compassion and generosity make you an unsung hero, not just for our show, but for the universe. We'll be thinking of you and Alex on September 9th.
如果你喜欢这一集或我们《YouTube.io》系列中的任何一集，请务必与朋友分享。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是NPR。请务必与朋友分享。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是NPR。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
If you liked this episode or any episode in our YouTube.io series, please be sure to share it with a friend. I'm Shankar Vedantam, and this is NPR. Please be sure to share it with a friend. I'm Shankar Vedantam, and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果您喜欢这一集或我们YouTube.io系列中的任何一集，请务必与朋友分享。我是Shankar Vedantam，这是NPR。请务必与朋友分享。我是Shankar Vedantam，这是NPR。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。